where Thomas called Jesus my Lord and my
God y John 2028 yes and they'd say that
Jesus actually corrected Thomas no he
didn't that's a lie point out verse John
42 no you can't go to John 424 you go to
John
4:24 John 2028 Jesus's response is in
29 show me where Jesus corrected him in
verse 29 don't run to John 424
424 isn't a corrective to what comes
years later and chapters later the
response of Jesus is in 29 show me where
he corrects him in verse
29 John
2829 okay John
2029 okay John 20
28-29 Thomas said to him my Lord and my
God and Jesus told him because you have
seen me you have believed blessed are
those who have not seen and yet have
believed where did he correct
29 uh there's nowhere after 28 now show
me in Luke 24 show me in Luke 24 where
Jesus corrects Thomas saying my Lord my
God I'll give you a million bucks if you
show it to me go
ahead um Jesus appears to his disciples
Luke
2438 what does that got to do with
Thomas because there nothing is said to
correct Thomas for calling him my Lord
and my God show it to me that's right so
they're gonna say this right
36 all the way to the end 36 okay I'll
go because that's where he appears to
the 11 not the 12 it says 11 Luke
24:36 all the way to the end show me
where in that context he corrects Thomas
saying that he is his Lord and God
please I'll give you a million bucks
because I don't think you understand
their argument I'm going to tell you
what their argument is what's their
argument because you told me John 420
I've never heard their argument but I'm
catching what you're saying yeah
john4 God is Spirit but then in Luke
2439 Jesus says a spirit does not have
Flesh and Bones as you see me have yeah
that's exactly what they're trying to
without hearing their argument God is my
witness I've never heard their argument
but I realized now why you went to John
4:24 and
2439 because I saw why you went there so
guys I'm being honest may God destroy my
pride I didn't know their argument but
now it's made the key oh because he
mentioned John 4:24 God is spirit and
those who worship Him must Worship in
spirit and truth but in Luke
24:39 Jesus says a spirit does not have
Flesh and Bones as you see me have
therefore since Jesus has Flesh and
Bones he can't be God because God is
Spirit that's the argument yes that's
exactly their argument that what they
prove to you because that tells you how
dishonest they are and their wicked sons
of the devil what they prove to you is
Jesus is not the father because if you
read John
4:24 the God that he says is spirit is
the
father and who told you Jesus is the
father so yes God the father is spirit
and he didn't become Flesh and Bones but
Jesus is not the father he's God the son
and he became
human now go read John 42324 to see who
that God is that's being said being
referred to as Spirit go to John
42324 the
father so yes we agree you're right
Jesus is not the father he is God but
he's not the father so you see how
stupid they are they're quoting a verse
where it says the father who is God is
not spirit amen because the father did
not become flesh but Jesus is God the
son he became flesh yes he's not the
father who remains Spirit he is the son
who is God that became flesh how does
that refute anything that Thomas
said can you explain
that yeah I can see that point now how
does that refute that when when Thomas
said my Lord and my God Jesus didn't
rebuke him he said Thomas you have seen
and believe believed what that I am the
Risen Lord and your God blessed are
those who do not see and believe where
did he rebuke him for that and then
secondly John 42324 read for us please
who is said to be God that is Spirit
read John
42324 oh my goodness bro what are you
blowing my drums man damn bro how old
are you but the hour is coming I'll
answer that later but I'm on 23 now so
but the hour is coming and now is when
the true worshippers will worship the
father in spirit and trth the
father it's right there yeah worship the
father what in spirit and Truth oh keep
roll for such the father seeks to
worship him God is spirit and those who
worship Him must Worship in spirit and
truth so who is the god that is
Spirit the
father so all you prove to me is that
Jesus is not the father
exactly because the father did not
become flesh the father is Spirit by
Nature he didn't become flesh but Jesus
the word who is God did become
flesh so all you prove proved he's not
the father that's all this passage
proves that's all this passage proves
he's not the father cuz the father is
the one that Jesus is referring to as
God who is Spirit last time I checked no
trinitarian thought Jesus is the father
but how does that refute the fact that
he is the word of the father who is God
that did become flesh he's God In the
Flesh and that's why Thomas could say to
the Risen Lord in his physical body you
are my Lord and my God and Jesus bless
him not rebuke him
how does that refute that I'm still
waiting yeah there's there's no
refutation on that no okay so you see
how silly that
argum yeah so can you show me in John 20
2829 where Jesus rebuked Thomas for
calling him my Lord and my
God I can't find that anywhere it's
nowhere now let me tell you why that's
the burial are you ready why it's the
burial for them I'm ready
Thomas is an Israelite right right now
the literal Greek by the way you don't
need to know Greek I'll send you link it
says and Thomas said to him said to
him the Greek is literally this and I'll
give you the link you don't even need to
read Greek it'll translate it for you he
literally
saido literally the Lord of me and the
god of me you are the Lord of me and the
god of me the Lord of me and the god of
me now you know why that's astonishing
why is that according to the Hebrew
Bible no Israelite no Israelite can call
someone other than Yahweh his Lord and
his God now let me get you link for the
Greek so you can see that he's saying it
to Jesus here it is for everyone else
and I'll send it to you in private chat
it's a Bible Hub it has it so here it is
for you in private chat
but if you look at it you'll see if you
click on the link folks it says
here EP I'm trying to sound pronounce it
like the Greeks would good luck with
that
epas and if you look it in English it
says answered Thomas and said to him to
him so he's talking to him the Lord of
me and the god of
me
right right that's right that's right
okay the Lord of me the god of you
right okay right now according to the
Hebrew Bible no Jew could worship
someone other than Yahweh as his Lord
and his God that's in the Hebrew Bible
the only God in Israelite could confess
is Yahweh himself now if Jesus was not
God but a man then he should have
rebuked Thomas and said no Thomas you're
a Jew like me we are to worship Yahweh
as our Lord and our God now go to Psalm
35 open up now don't read the NIV here
that drops the ball read something else
yes we Psalm 35 verse
23 Psalm
35:23 stir up thyself and awake to my
judgment even unto my cause my God and
my Lord so wait
Jehovah Yahweh is the psalmist
what my my Lord my God and my Lord to
Jehovah you're my God and my Lord Thomas
says to Jesus You're My Lord and my God
that's the same
thing it's the same thing yeah that's
right yeah but it's reverse order Thomas
says my Lord and my God he says my God
and my Lord and if you look at the Greek
translation of Psalm Psalm 34:23 it says
say the god of me and the Lord of me
it's
literally the god of me and the Lord of
me but in the Greek of John Thomas says
to
Jesus the Lord of me and the god of me
so the pomas says the god of me and the
Lord of me Thomas says to Jesus the Lord
of me and the god of
me they're very
similar but um
could they're identical not similar say
like two persons like my Lord and then
my
God him he didn't it wasn't clear the
him or said said to him not
them all right well that's a yeah that's
I see
that how are they gonna say two people
when it says Thomas said to him not them
yeah I catch
that yes so how they going to get around
this there there's nothing I can think
of
now yeah they have to come up with don't
know the Bible they don't know the Bible
they misquote the Bible they butcher the
Bible see God is Spirit yeah God the
father is Spirit we don't say Jesus is
the father and God the Father spirit
because he didn't become flesh but the
same John says the word who is God he
did become flesh without ceasing to be
God so where's the problem man